Nachrichten des Tages heute mit niedrige
Sirin einen schönen guten Abend ihnen
allen das Wichtigste vom Sport später
wieder mit dir Christine und Fußball
dabei guten Abend und wir verschaffen
uns jetzt wieder einen Überblick
die Wirtschaft fördern und den
Amtsschimmel zügeln die Bundesregierung
beschließt Erleichterungen für
Unternehmen und will unnötige Bürokratie
abbauen
bange Stunden in Florida Hurrikan Italia
ist auf Land getroffen und wütet mit
Windgeschwindigkeiten von mehr als 200
Stundenkilometer
Filmfestival mit Einschränkungen in
Venedig fehlen viele US-Stars wegen des
Streiks in Hollywood Eröffnungsfilm ist
jetzt ein Kriegsdrama aus Italien
[Musik]
auffallen durch harte Arbeit und nicht
mehr durch lauten Streit des hat sich
die Bundesregierung bei ihrer Klausur
auf Schloss Meseberg vorgenommen den
Alarm rufen aus der Wirtschaft setzt die
Ampel ein Reform Bündel entgegen das
wieder Aufschwung bringen soll weniger
Bürokratie und Steuererleichterungen
wurden beschlossen strittig bleibt der
verbilligte Strom für die Industrie über
die Ergebnisse von Meseberg Patricia
Wiedemeier
es ist genau 12 Uhr als die Spitzen der
Ampel vor die Presse treten hi nun
irgendwie passend für die Lage im Land
und wohl auch für diese Koalition
Einsichten wir sind eine Regierung wo
gehämmert geschraubt wird das führt zu
Geräuschen wie sie schon festgestellt
haben aber es kommt eben auch was raus
kam in Meseberg vor allem Entlastungen
für die derzeit schwächelnde Wirtschaft
verabschiedet wurde unter anderem das
wachstumschancengesetz vorgesehen sind
steuerliche Entlastungen für die
Wirtschaft im Volumen von gut 7
Milliarden Euro jährlich für besonders
klimafreundliche Investitionen gibt es
Prämien und wer neue Wohnungen baut kann
auf Erleichterungen bei der Steuer
hoffen auf dies alles wirklich umgesetzt
wird ist offen da bereits einige
Bundesländer Einspruch erhoben haben und
der Wirtschaft ist dies noch zu wenig
wir brauchen deutlich mehr hinsichtlich
in der Frage der steuerlichen Entlastung
was die Unternehmenssteuern angeht wir
brauchen bei der Frage der Energiepreise
eine Entlastung sowohl für Verbraucher
als auch insbesondere für sehr
energieintensive Unternehmen doch gerade
beim Thema industriestrompreis gab es
keine Einigung grüne und SPD-Fraktion
fordern ist FDP und Kanzler lehnen es ab
zu unserer Strategie gehört auch
strukturell dafür zu sorgen dass wir
geringe Stromkosten in Deutschland haben
indem wir mit noch neuem Tempo die
erneuerbaren Energien
mir ist es nicht zusammen heute
jedenfalls nicht
der industriestrompreis er könnte zum
nächsten Streit in der Ampel führen doch
diesmal soll es dann alles anders vor
allem leiser werden wir werden Hämmern
und Klopfen aber mit Schalldämpfer nach
zwei Tagen Klausur demonstriert die
Ampel Einigkeit und verspricht Besserung
wieder mal
Stichwort
Bürokratieabbau was wird noch gebraucht
und was kann weg ist ja immer die
zentrale Frage beim Entrümpeln ob zu
Hause auf dem Dachboden oder eben im
Gesetzbuch die Regierung hat jetzt also
geprüft welche Formulare und
Vorschriften sich überholt haben das
Ergebnis dieser Inventur soll die
Wirtschaft um 2,3 Milliarden Euro pro
Jahr entlasten einige Beispiele zeigt
Julia Schröter
der Meldeschein im Hotel jeder kennt ihn
doch er soll bald Geschichte sein Daten
wie Name Geburtsdatum aber auch
Mitreisende zumindest von deutschen
Staatsbürgern müssen Gastgeber dann
nicht mehr erfassen
bisher ist das noch für jeden Reisenden
nötig inklusive einem Jahr
Aufbewahrungsfrist für jeden Schein
Stichwort mehr digital statt auf Papier
das soll in Wirtschaftsunternehmen in
vielen Bereichen umgesetzt werden
Arbeitszeugnisse etwa soll es künftig
auch elektronisch geben können im
Privatbereich wird es ebenfalls
digitaler die Kündigung eines
Mietverhältnisses beispielsweise soll
bald elektronisch möglich sein
weniger Bürokratie auch am Flughafen
über den Chip im Reisepass sollen sofern
der Reisende zustimmt Daten an die
airline-
und noch ein Kabinettsbeschluss die
digitale Patientenakte soll ab 2025
Pflicht werden es sei denn man
widerspricht ausdrücklich die
Datensicherheit sei gewährleistet
Versicherte Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach in der Akte werden Diagnosen
Laborergebnisse Röntgenbilder Rezepte
und andere Informationen zusammengefasst
den Ärzten soll sie helfen sich ein Bild
vom Zustand des Patienten zu machen auch
die Forschung soll davon profitieren ja
von Gesundheit bis Wirtschaft wenn sie
noch mal nachlesen wollen was die
Ampelkoalition beschlossen hatte auf
Schloss Meseberg online haben wir die
wichtigsten Punkte zusammengefasst
jederzeit auf unserer ZDF heute App
Bayerns Landesregierung aus CSU und
Freien Wählern befindet sich seit dem
Wochenende im krisenmodus freie
wählerchef Aiwanger soll zu Schulzeiten
ein antisemitisches Flugblatt zumindest
besessen haben dass sein Bruder verfasst
haben will erstmals seit Bekanntwerden
des Falles hat sich der
vizeministerpräsident jetzt persönlich
zu Wort gemeldet ich bin weder Antisemit
noch Extremist sondern ich bin ein
demokratisch bin ein Menschenfreund kein
Menschen Feind und insofern sage ich das
wirklich dass ich hier für die letzten
Jahrzehnte alle Handy ins Feuer legen
kann und wo sie in Jugendzeiten hier
diskutiert wird wundert mich etwas aber
es ist auf alle Fälle so dass vielleicht
in der Jugendseite seine oder andere so
oder so interpretiert werden kann wo
soll es 15-Jähriger hier mir vorgeworfen
wird aber auf alle Fälle ich sage
seitdem Erwachsenenalter die letzten
Jahrzehnte kein Antisemit keine
Extremist sondern Menschen Freund
da wollen wir noch mal nachfragen in
München bei Stefan leifert Stefan wie
ordnest du das Statements oder die
Statements von Aiwanger ein
ja man kann daraus dreierlei ableiten
erstens ist es ein erstes kleines
Eingeständnis von Hubert Aiwanger das
ist in dessen Jugend etwas gab was dann
anders gegeben hat zu den Vorwürfen die
heute auf dem Tisch liegen das ist neu
bisher Hubert Aiwanger die Vorwürfe ja
recht pauschal abstreiten lassen
zweitens man kann erkennen wie seine
Verteidigungslinie aussehen wird er will
das ganze als Jugendsünde abtun sagt das
sein Vorgänger die lange her sein er sei
15 16 gewesen und habe sich danach auch
nichts zu Schulden kommen lassen
überhaupt hält er das Ganze für eine
Schmutzkampagne wie er sagt die in
politisch vernichten soll drittens zum
Verhältnis zwischen ihm und Markus Söder
und damit in der bayernkoalition sagt er
die Lage sei sehr sehr ernst er habe den
Fragenkatalog bekommen den die CSU
gestern entworfen hat und wolle die
Fragen beantworten also unterm Strich
das ist kein Befreiungsschlag es ist
deine erste Antwort es ist aber noch
nicht die differenzierte Antwort auf die
25 Fragen die Hubert Aiwanger jetzt
vorliegen vorerst bleibt Hubert Aiwanger
viel zum Ministerpräsident und Minister
hier in Bayern auf Abruf Stefan vielen
Dank für die Einordnung nach München
ja unter Druck steht auch die
Linkspartei die Fraktionsspitze hat
ihren Rückzug angekündigt und die Partei
die befindet sich in ihrer bislang wohl
größten Krise seit Monaten kritisiert
ex-fraktionschefin Wagenknecht den
parteikurs es geht um unterschiedliche
Positionen etwa zum Ukraine Krieg
weswegen Wagenknecht die Gründung einer
neuen Partei erwägt über eine
Krisensitzung der Fraktion berichtet
Andrea Maurer
Dietmar Bartsch hat gesagt dass er für
das Amt des Fraktionsvorsitzenden nicht
mehr antritt auch seine
ko-fraktionschefin will nicht mehr doch
die Partei hat keine mehrheitsfähige
Nachfolge gefunden und jetzt bleiben
beide im Amt ich habe eine Verantwortung
übernommen auch als angetreten habe und
ich lass natürlich jetzt nicht am
nächsten Tag den Stift fallen die
Fraktion hat nun beschlossen die
Vorstands weil die am 04.09 stattfinden
sollte zu verschieben für das Lager um
Sarah Wagenknecht ein weiterer Beleg für
das Versagen der Partei Spitze Partei
Verstand da nicht in der Lage geeignet
die Kandidaten zu finden wo man davon
ausgegangen wie ihr seht eine Mehrheit
und das ist ein Desaster das ist
tatsächlich ein Desaster das ist der
Vorstand dieser Partei verursacht hat in
seiner bisherigen Politik der Zerlegung
der Partei die beiden Parteichef Janine
Wissler und Martin schürde waren stehen
für ein Interview nicht zur Verfügung
sie verweisen auf den Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer überhaupt gar nicht zu
sagen wer hat jetzt hier wie Schuld
sondern diese Fraktionssitzung ist im
Vorstand der Parteivorsitzenden und der
Fraktionsvorsitzenden gefolgt wie gesagt
haben wir wollen es noch mal versuchen
nehmen uns deswegen die Zeit und einem
möglichst breit getragenen
Personalvorschlag zu machen die
Verschiebung der Wahl wird die Krise
nicht lösen sondern wahrscheinlich nur
verhärten die Partei wird sich weiter
zerreiben in Personalfragen und über
allem hängt noch das Damoklesschwert
Sarah Wagenknecht die womöglich schon
bald Ihre neue Partei gründen könnte
wann die Vorstandswahlen und stattfindet
ist offen fraglich auch ob sie überhaupt
noch stattfindet oder ob sich die
Fraktion nicht vorher schon spaltet
die Hoffnung dass sich der Anstieg der
Preise im Laufe des Jahres deutlich
abschwächt er fühlt sich bislang nicht
die Inflation hält sich weiter
hartnäckig auf hohem Niveau denn vor
allem Energie und Lebensmittel bleiben
teuer immerhin geht die Inflationsrate
minimal zurück um 0,1 Punkte auf aktuell
6,1 Prozent eben August diese vorläufige
Schätzung hat das Statistische Bundesamt
heute veröffentlicht
jetzt zum Krieg in der Ukraine dort hat
es in mehreren Regionen massiven
russischen Beschuss gegeben nach
offiziellen Angaben wurden mindestens
sechs Menschen getötet zwei davon in der
Hauptstadt Kiew wo Trümmer
abgeschossener Raketen auf Gebäude
stürzten zwei weitere Menschen wurden
dabei verletzt Moskau meldet unterdessen
Drohnenangriffe aufgebiete in Russland
vor allem auf den Westen
der ägyptische Staat geht mit Härte
gegen
Oppositionelle Vor- und offenbar sind
auch ihre Verwandten nicht mehr sicher
Sascha eine deutsche mit ägyptischen
Wurzeln kämpft für die Freilassung ihres
Vaters er ist vor einigen Tagen bei der
Einreise in Kairo verhaftet worden die
30-Jährige geht davon aus dass ihr Vater
aus Rache inhaftiert wurde weil sie
selbst macht aber als Sissi vor acht
Jahren in Berlin medienwirksam als
Mörder beschimpft hatte unsere
Reporterin Anna Feist hat Vater
getroffen
warten auf Nachricht vom Vater der sitzt
seit zwölf Tagen zu Unrecht in Haft sagt
seine Tochter ich bin die politische
aktive ich bin diejenige die sozusagen
dass Regime kritisiert hat mein Vater
hat nichts mit zu tun Rückblick Frau
Merkel verbieten sie mir nicht das Wort
er
ist ab 2015 während einer
Pressekonferenz von Kanzlerin Merkel und
dem ägyptischen Präsident als sie sie
protestiert vor Jean lautstadt ich habe
mich für Ägypten eingesetzt letztendlich
mit meinem Hintergrund als deutsche
Person ja die aber aufgewachsen ist mit
mit dem immer mit dem Ziel sich für
Menschenrechte einzusetzen acht Jahre
später so vermutet die 30-Jährige folge
nun die Rache des ägyptischen
Präsidenten anders als sie habe der
Vater keinen deutschen Pass ist der
ägyptischen Justiz ausgeliefert
siebenhaft als Einschüchterung das sei
kein Einzelfall
es geht darum Druck auszuüben indem sie
Angehörige verhaften damit
Regierungskritiker oder Journalisten
Schweigen das passiert ja häufig
doch Schweigen wird
vergangene Woche demonstriert sie allein
auf den Straßen Kairos völlig unerwartet
kann sie am Montag erstmals den Vater
besuchen im Gefängnis Trakt für
politische Häftlinge es ging ihm gut so
weit er schlafe auf dem Boden habe
abgenommen er Abschied fällt schwer
wir haben uns umarmt und er hat mir
gesagt bleib stark und alles wird gut
gestern dann gibt es schlechte
Nachrichten die Haft werde um 15 Tage
verlängert wie es weitergeht völlig
unklar
wieder ein Putsch in Afrika diesmal in
Gabun wenige Tage nach der umstrittenen
Präsidentschaftswahl hat das Militär
nach eigenen Angaben die gerade
wiedergewählte Regierung gestürzt
Offiziere erklärten im Fernsehen dem
Regime werde ein Ende gesetzt und die
Wahl für nichtig erklärt genauso wie der
Sieg von Präsident Ali Bongo er steht
unter Hausarrest Bongos Familie regiert
das Land seit mehr als 55 Jahren er
selbst ist seit 14 Jahren an der Macht
ja sind bange Stunden für die Menschen
im US-Bundesstaat Florida dort ist
Hurrikan Italia auf Land getroffen mit
Windgeschwindigkeiten von mehr als 200
km pro Stunde zieht der Wirbelsturm
einmal quer über Florida er sorgt für
schwere Überschwemmungen und
Stromausfälle experten stufen die Lage
als extrem gefährlich ein clauds-
der peitschende Sturm treibt schwimmende
Trümmer durch Ortschaften Hurricane
Italia zeigt seine zerstörerische Kraft
als er morgen auf Land traf stand an
vielen Küstenabschnitten schnell alles
unter Wasser die Behörden hatten gewarnt
vor Meter hohen Sturmfluten
der Sturm ist inzwischen über Florida
hinweggezogen
such und Rettungsteams sind ausgewärmt
die Nationalgarde ist bereits an
verschiedenen Orten im Einsatz sie
werden größere Teile der Straßen
Freiräumen und Trümmer beseitigen die
herumgeflogen sind
bereits jetzt sind mehr als 250.000
Haushalte ohne Strom
Wassertemperaturen von bis zu 31 Grad im
Golf von Mexiko haben Italia immer
stärker werden lassen auf dem Weg an die
Küste die Regierung hatte bereits im
Vorfeld Unterstützung zugesagt wir sind
da so lang wie nötig sie sollen alles
haben was sie brauchen
die Sorge der Katastrophenschützer gilt
vor allem den Menschen die trotz der
dringlichen Warnungen dageblieben sind
sobald das Wasser zurückgeht beginnt für
alle hier das große Aufräumen
jetzt schauen wir woanders hin nach
Venedig für viele eine der
romantischsten Städte der Welt dort
starten heute wieder die Internationalen
Filmfestspiele und die gelten immer auch
als großes Warmlaufen für die
Oscar-Verleihungen entsprechend hoch ist
dort dann immer auch die Dichte an
großen Hollywood Stars in diesem Jahr
allerdings bleiben die allermeisten dem
Festival fern warum das so ist und wer
davon profitiert erfahren wir jetzt von
Annette hilsenbeck
vor wenigen Momenten ging es los auf dem
roten Teppich für den Eröffnungsfilm in
Venedig das italienische Marine Drama
kommandante ein Ersatz denn die
Hollywood-Produktion Challengers wurde
kurzfristig abgesagt Grund die
Hollywood-Schauspieler Strecken seit
Wochen und machen auch keine Werbung für
ihre Filme
aber insgesamt wird es wie immer eine
große Party sein
Premieren von großen
Hollywood-Produktionen wie the killer
mit Michael Fassbender oder Maestro von
und mit Bradley Cooper finden statt ohne
Stars mit weniger Glamour die
Hollywood-Schauspieler fordern höhere
Gagen und Regeln beim Einsatz
künstlicher Intelligenz um nicht durch
Kunstfiguren ersetzt zu werden und nicht
nur sie streiten sondern auch die
Drehbuchautoren die Jury um
Jury-Präsident Damian chassel heute bei
der Pressekonferenz der Regisseur des
Oscar prämierten Filmes lalaland zeigte
sich per T-Shirt solidarisch mit den
Streikenden 23 Filme stellen sich im
Wettbewerb bis 9 September im Rennen um
den Goldenen Löwen für den besten Film
sehr gut und von Venedig geht's jetzt
nach New York zu den US Open tennis ist
eine Sache zuerst ein Lichtblick Eva
lies aus Hamburg die erst zweite
deutsche Spielerin die zweite Runde
erreicht hat bei ihrem Hauptrunde mit
sechs zwei sechs eins gegen die
Amerikanerin Robin und gomery tapfer
gekämpft aber nicht belohnt Dominik
Köpfe aus Furtwangen
Aufschlag noch steht es 0:0 da knickt er
oben im größten Spiel seiner Karriere
Verdacht auf Bänderriss
aber aufgeben nach nur ein paar Minuten
gegen die Nummer eins der Welt das will
er nicht dann habe ich mir noch als Ziel
gesetztem ja solange wie möglich
durchzuhalten haben
ja eine Stunde musste hier draußen
bleiben kannst du nicht machen mit so
viel Zuschauern und ja das ist so ein
Ende nimmt es natürlich ganz bitte
vier Spiele dann geht es nicht mehr bei
2:26 und 2:3 verabschiedet er sich von
Carlos der Spanier bleibt Turnier
Favorit
und zum Fußball Streik statt
Abschlusstraining Paris Stadt Frankfurt
Stürmerstar kolumbiani forciert seinen
Abgang von der Eintracht hin zu PSG
ziemlich groß
mit viel Unruhe und ohne ihren top
Torjäger Randal colomani geht es für
Frankfurt ins Play auf Rückspiel gegen
Lewski Sofia der wechselstreit und den
Franzosen eskaliert er will seinen
Wechsel zu Paris saint-germa erzwingen
und bestreikt dir das Abschlusstraining
Konsequenz das Spiel findet ohne
Frankfurt besten Stürmer statt keine
gute Situation in der wir jetzt gerade
sind weil natürlich da vielleicht auch
nicht optimal Verhalten im Großen und
Ganzen muss man aber sagen das andere
sehr sehr guter Junge Paris bietet 80
Millionen für kolomani doch Frankfurt
braucht ihn auch um in die Gruppenphase
der Conference liegt einzuziehen im
Hinspiel kam die Eintracht nicht über
einen eins zu eins gegen Sophia hinaus
der FC Bayern München hat seinen neuen
Sportdirektor vorgestellt Christoph
Freund der 46-Jährige Österreicher
bezeichnet seine Aufgabe beim deutschen
Rekordmeister als absoluten Traum nach
17 Jahren bei RB Salzburg unterschrieb
er bei den Bayern für vier Jahre er gilt
als Talente Entdecker und
nachwuchsförderer und der erste
Arbeitstag am Freitag 1.9 vielen Dank
Christine wir haben noch die Zahlen vom
Mittwochslotto hier sind sie 23 32 42 43
46 48 die Superzahl lautet 1 weitere
Gewinnzahlen und Infos auf lotto.zdf.de
und auf der ZDF Textseite 557
mit Gewitter geht es weiter aber es wird
auch wärmer mehr dazu gleich von Herrli
ab 21:45 Uhr empfehle ich Ihnen das
heute journal mit Christian Sievers das
war's von uns zumindest für heute wir
sehen uns morgen wenn Sie mögen schönen
Abend noch für Sie
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter im Westen ist ja
heute schon dieses Frontensystem
angekommen hat hier Regen gebracht und
wird weiteren Regen bringen im Osten und
nach Norden und auch Gewitter sind dabei
schauen wir uns die Nacht an und da gibt
es in der Mitte Schauer und Gewitter das
ganze verlagert sich ostwärts und nach
Norden und schwächt sich im Laufe der
Nacht allmählich ab Temperaturen sinken
dabei auf 13 Grad an der Ostsee ganz im
Westen einstellige Werte von sieben bis
acht Grad und morgen dann erst einmal in
der Mitte trocken aber dann bilden sich
hier Schauer und Gewitter so ähnlich
auch nach Norden hin ganz im Süden ja da
gibt's einzelne Schauer im Südwesten
zeigt sich die Sonne häufiger bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 23 Grad dort
sonst 17° z.B hier im hessischen
Bergland deutlich kühler aber oft liegen
wir um die 20 Grad Marke die nächsten
Tage
wir haben es immer noch mit schauen und
Gewittern zu tun die können vor allem am
Freitag in der Mitte kräftiger ausfallen
Werte 18 bis 26 Grad und dann sind die
schauen Gewitter seltener dafür wird es
wärmer und die Temperaturen steigen bis
auf 28 Grad ein schönen Abend